[Musique]
les présidents est inquiétante mais les
derniers rapports
la cocaïne est plus réservé seulement à
la châtaigne la cocaïne est produite
dans mon pays
elle est consommée aux états unis en
dépit de nos meilleurs efforts de la
cocaïne continue à entrer illégalement
dans notre pays et ce de manière
inquiétante
pablo n'a mis que dix ans à bâtir
l'industrie la plus rentable de toute
l'histoire
je suis la seule journaliste
autorisé à assister à leur premier
congrès le
produite dans votre pays entre dans
merde et cela nous inquiète
jusqu'où tu comptes à leurs
représentants à la chambre des députés
[Applaudissements]
le ministre de la justice a été
assassinée à porter le président qu'est
ce qui se passe là elle est pas de style
sur tout le territoire soit on est tous
coupables
soit on est tous innocents
[Musique]
et on sait tous que signifie la guerre
celui qui a le plus de cash en sort
vainqueur
et entre nous tous ici qui a plus
d'argent à blanc je crois que tu perds
la tête
tu n'écoutes pas seul
je vous ouvre à il vous entraînera vous
le savez très bien
aidez nous à retrouver seulement un
milliard de pesos ses tubes aux moutons
vous de profondes pour chaque flic d'ego
mais je payerai 28 euros
[Musique]
maintenant vous allez tous me coûter ma
part il dit
si vous devez vous des centres pour
ignorer jusqu'à ce que vous creux vire
vous m'avez entendu son nom d'yves
albarello sert des potins
t'as fait fortune pablo qu'est ce que tu
veux de plus du respect